hier ces dernières semaines une
trentaine d'enfants rendait sont arrivés
en france pour y être soigné et les
familles qui les ont accueillis dénonce
elle aussi l'incapacité des
gouvernements à arrêter ce génocide
reportage à lyon de françoise vallée et
olivier jacque la
moto ni et tutsis et c'est pour cela
qu'ils ont voulu la tuer là-bas au
rwanda elle a laissé sa maman et son
frère les seuls survivants de la famille
après le massacre malgré leurs blessures
ils ont réussi à marcher jusqu'à
l'hôpital la petite fille de 7 ans a été
frappé à coups de machette sur la tête à
l'épaule et au visage mais home ou toni
as de la chance elle a pu être opéré
là-bas des milliers de blessés attendent
aujourd'hui malheureusement nous
médecins du monde nous sommes devenus un
petit peu des spectateurs de l'horreur
cette situation ne peut plus durer et il
serait temps que les états puissent
convient de parler de l'europe on vient
de voter pour l'europe que les états
prennent leurs responsabilités et ils
essayent de régler ce conflit d'une
manière efficace
pour la famille faivre accueillir un
enfant rwandais n'est qu'un petit geste
qui ne doit en aucun cas masquer le
silence de la communauté internationale
sur ce conflit je pense qu'il faut que
les gens les gens réagissent
il faut en parler autour de soi il faut
que la france se positionne il faut que
l'onu cesse de dire oui nous enverrons
des caisses que bleu peut-être sont-ils
prêts dans trois semaines si tout va
bien et pendant trois semaines combien
d'enfants et d'adultes vont encore
mourir
à son réveil ce matin au moût tony a dit
qu'elle était bien mais qu'elle voudrait
qu'on amène le rwanda ici